what if apex legends had robot dogs a
disgrace titanfall pilot and an Eastern
European bodybuilder you ever thought
about that term I think about it daily
what if indeed well I'm glad that you've
come to the right place then I've been
playing a lot of apex legends and we've
been thinking about what other champions
would make a good fit one of us has been
more successful than the other I got
some good ideas so basically we've we've
got two ideas each and we're going to
pitch them to you the viewers we've also
had a artist's rendering a
world-renowned artist yet one of the
finest craftsmen in GameSpot has done
yeah we've given them descriptions and
they've taken the descriptions I made an
artistic portrayal we should probably
say that we are not trying to present
balanced characters hello
so before before anyone thinks this is
bad this isn't make sense we get it
we're not game designers we're just here
with a few fun thoughts about characters
that we'd like to see in apex legends
the first one I'd like to see is one
that I mean is probably about the only
one that might make a lot of sense and
something that's been talked about a lot
but the character I've come up with is
called mutiny and that's it's a pilot a
titanfall pilot that disobeyed their
orders they managed to escape with it's
not like the full Titan kit like a
limited Titan kit so there's got bits
and pieces they haven't got all their
perks like some of the uniform seems to
be from different factions they might
have scavenged it from everywhere don't
really know what faction they used to
fight for bit of a mystery
keeps their helmet on they David they
want to hide their face a bit like
bloodhound and this is what they look
like so what's going on here Robert and
Lori Rob Rob has taken why is he gonna
lose pilot I mean I guess the crime he
committed was raid in the
in mess hall I guess he looks like he's
unloading a massive on that wall I think
that says that says boost will get into
his abilities in a moment but that boy's
[Music]
yeah I can't say my thick boy to base is
I will say is done a great job of
putting in the abilities I really like
the idea of having a like a bigger like
a physically bigger titanfall pilot but
it's still capable of moving like a tile
and for pilot to some degree that's
that's part of his ability to pitch the
background and we're gonna go through
each of the characters abilities as well
huge fan of shooting a is an SMG with
one arm Yemen is passive is the double
jump it doesn't work as the same as it
does in titanfall 2 mu new you can do
like smaller secondary jumps after their
initial jump that's their passive their
their ability is something that
complements that double jump and it's a
hover which is obviously another ability
from titanfall too so you can use it to
stay in the air for a few seconds maybe
get off a good shot scout an area that
sort of stuff
pressing jump again will cancel the
hopper in case you'll get shot at see I
have thought about it and then the
ultimate is advanced movement so well
they're not well they've been out of
combat for a while as you can see by the
burgers and they're definitely the pilot
they used to be I see you've leaned on
that they still have the abilities of
advanced movement but can only keep up
for short bursts and they can share
those abilities with their team so for a
few seconds once you pet for your
ultimate ability you give you and your
teammates the ability to double jump to
wall run bunnyhop all that sort of stuff
so like titanfall 2 works great tool for
getting out of Dodge or get a really
good flank on the enemy I really like
the idea of like a character that has
escaped the titanfall corner of the
universe and made it to this point and
like has a weird mysterious backstory
and is unwilling to reveal his like face
because he might be some sort of like
criminal from my only horrendously ugly
he could be ugly it could be like he's
really really like well known as
decorate Sojo in the pineapple universe
and doesn't want to you know reveal that
he's actually a minion for little too
high and like has been hitting Jesus so
we'll get into your first character now
mm-hmm so my first character is called
lockdown it's a female dog handler with
some very very good boys
already sold on the dogs so lockdown
served as like a police riot officer in
London okay or whatever the titanfall
universe his version of a free his place
is she worked like really hard every day
to train her dogs and got super super
close but obviously dogs on him all as
time pass she realized that they weren't
gonna be around for long
so she did some mad illegal stuff and
arranged to have her dogs that kind of
like their identities and existence put
into two robot dogs sick this inevitably
meant that she was also now criminal
which meant she had to take her dogs and
leave but she used to work in law
enforcement and because of that she kind
of retains her sense of justice okay so
instead of like just fading away she
becomes kind of like frontier vigilante
justice lady with two very good boys at
her side sounds extremely chaotic did he
exactly chaotic good so there's two dogs
the first one is called s00 t30 yes so
this is like a larger larger more
ferocious dog and the second dog is like
a smaller one
it's called SW - 33 P sweet so we've got
Zoey and sweep - very good boys it
doesn't matter this is a fantasy
universe this is reference to an old-ass
British show that none of the Americans
are going
I was so happy when this happened
originally there were a we could but
your badges so use armored and super
aggressive to enemies and sweepers kind
of like this x-ray vision style thing
that allows it to kind of see objects
and enemies in a reasonable field of
vision around itself
okay so lockdowns passive is called ammo
hound and it allows her to use her dogs
to sniff out a mall nearby obviously
ammo is really hard to come by and this
is a character that will make that
slightly easier the intricacy there is
it's not just all ammo so it's
effectively ammo that anyone pings from
the inventory as needing so if vlog
damping's
for heavy ammo yeah the heavy ammo up
here nearby yeah okay yeah so that will
alleviate some of the resource haunting
issues that a lot of people are faced
with when in the thick of battle the
ability that lockdown has is called pin
and this is using the dog - god a downed
enemy so effectively like we said
earlier stops them from moving around a
lot and giving away your position when
you're in the middle of a like a
firefight I reckon that's very useful
because I get paid up constantly and I'm
one of those people that leaves down
people to make sure that I'm clear
before taking them out properly yeah so
I need a little dog friend to help me
out and then lockdowns ultimate is
unleash the hound and this is where as
depends
[Laughter]
this is where she sends out Sooey who's
capable of taking some damage because it
has armor you send out in a specific
direction basically like a line and any
enemies that encounters on the way it
will start attacking it's kind of like
Bob from overwatch Ash's ultimate it's
not I also kind of like the dogs in what
Call of Duty was it was it world of war
well the war had it was the first one
yeah and I think they came back in more
recent one one a few years ago and those
ones are real fast and this city's not
as fast but will require like at least
two players on a squad to focus it down
or maybe like a well-placed grenade
timed grenade something take people that
have cover yeah effectively it's like a
pincer attack it can set up but you'd
have to be like welcome
coordinator actually make good on that
so that is locked down what happens if
you shoot the dog the dog dog is fine a
dog works like Bob it's good just get
uploaded back yes that's the thing yes
unlimited potential they can just be
downloaded into a new dog chassis my
second hero champion is named holster
and it's an arms dealer who was muscled
out of their business by a rival
criminal organization so he lost his
money his business his contacts but all
the stock parts of our own guns that he
had in the frontier he still knows where
they are so he feels like becoming an
apex legend maybe the exposure that he
needs to get there shady little business
back on track and might give them the
possibility to get some revenge on the
people that muscled him out but this is
the artist rendering of him as you can
see he's fully donned in criminal attire
I think it has to be like black boiler
suit and yeah it doesn't look like a it
looks like a so much like a dog's house
in a way it looks like it's also done a
fart and destroyed everything behind I
think that's the interpretation of one
of his abilities so his passive is deep
pockets instead of the normal eighty
rounds of ammunition per inventory slot
because obviously it's a gun and he has
of this ammo he can hold 100 per stack
so you know a bit more in the way of
ammo reserves his ability is covering
fire the holster will only use the
finest of ammunition as gems so any that
he finds that he deems kind of less
quality or less worthy or you know
pretty shoddy he'll bundle them together
in a satchel and throw them when throw
and they'll start popping off at the
sound of gunfire after a couple of
seconds and this sound could be used to
draw an enemy it's like an ambush or if
it's close enough it will start doing
damage
basically like kinda like a decoy
grenade and then but also you know like
set there's a little bit damage will
ping the HUD to say that as you know
enemy's firing at you
distraction tool basically but that
ultimate is called get some so while
selling bullets is great staying alive
is better so in dire situations hostile
will quote-unquote lend some rounds of
ammunition to its teammates letting them
hook up to the ammo reserves that they
carry on their back which effectively
gives them unlimited ammunition for a
few seconds now it kind of works like
lifeline you have to be very close to
life lights drone right to be very close
to holster to get this benefit so the
bonus is that you can start shooting
loads and loads and loads and loads of
rounds but you are grouped up together
which obviously makes you quite
vulnerable yeah but I think that be that
sounds like a really good again it's
another thing that I struggle with
there's like ammo and that seems like a
really interesting way to create this
like support character yeah functions
basically support I feel like it would
make like machine guns really viable the
end game if you push was like three of
you with machine guns and you just hold
our left-click with a bow and trigger
you just not having to reload and you
guys like 7 seconds of just horrendous
to firepower someone speaking you at
that point you have three heavies from
Team Fortress it's coming at ya exactly
1914 yeah it costs four hundred thousand
dollars to fire this weapon for 12
seconds
so my last character is called Maria
she's quite um please
she's a ukrainian purple haired shopper
that has conquered the traditional
sports world and is now setting her
sights on the apex competition am you've
made Zarya yeah
perhaps yes yeah your phone with Azaria
cover on it you just describes Aria
Ukraine this is Mario okayed yeah this
is this pretty much Daria anyone who
knows me knows that I love Zaria she's
my main in overwatch I need her
everywhere put Zarya in Street fire up
or in Smash put her in the next burnout
game put her in the next skate she
functions quite similar to Soria
you'll be surprised to learn a passive
ability is called super set and this
kind of speeds up how long it takes when
you use an item to recover shields okay
so you know when you have trees yeah you
get a little bar if you're close to her
and that's the important thing you need
to be really close to her because it's a
super set so she's supporting you you
just kind of spotting you yeah but like
if you're really close to her that
passive ability will make it easier for
you to quickly recover and stay kind of
in the fight and it's important because
it kind of encourages you to form up
when you're in a sticky spot so this
will make players kind of regroup on
Mario you nearly said sorry yeah and and
they're like safer when they recovering
their shield resource her ability is
called spotter and this is she can
effectively give a shield to one person
and it absorbs a small amount of damage
before breaking like my good friends are
yes but effectively is it's forgiving
teammate it's just enough time and
breathing room to reposition without
taking a mad amount of damage and
because the characters in Apex can move
and slide you could probably travel
quite a decent amount of distance with
that shield even though it's very very
limited so it's basically a
repositioning tour of sorts or but if
you're good enough I mean and if you're
quick enough and you use at the right
moment you can also use a flanking
well you've obviously thought about this
quite a lot and this is wrapping up with
with your description no I don't know
what she's shopping berry Lord check I'd
love it if she'd like through humor I
actually like hat yeah yeah that would
be amazing
I'm getting not gonna lie Robert Henry
this is not the vision well I will say
the robbers up very later yes and the
Maurya was the last one he did so to
even get this far I think yeah it gives
a good sense of her stature and of power
yeah it seems like one arm is massive
other arm is are osius they're really
small I mean this is an interpretation
of Mario it is the incorrect
interpretation of Mario is the correct
one sorry I'm sorry Oh with purple hair
which is I'm sure no problem at all for
but I appreciate the interpretation
regardless she looks very ferocious here
I think my favorite is mutiny yeah your
favorite is your own one yeah my mind's
Mario yeah Muni looks really good really
cool as well I like lock down a lot the
dog is pretty much exactly whoa thank
you no massive like jaws I like the
little bone that she's holding as well
very very cool I like those a lot well
those are are you know potentially
terrible ideas if you have ideas for
apex legend champions put in the comment
section below
maybe if there's a call for it we'll do
a follow-up video using your suggestions
and get the talented mr. handler e to
draw those up too he hasn't agreed to
this no no
or if you want to redraw any of our pics
having that'll be amazing yeah sorry
that's it please please give me the
Mario I hope you enjoyed this dumb
little video thank you so much for
watching and we'll hopefully see you in
the next one bye
[Music]